Supergirl
yeah you're 18 years old yeah I turned
19 when I was filming and you know
Schwartz directed that yes who directed
a lot of Smallville episodes he did many
I loved you know oh yeah we love him
Michael Michael please please be quiet
please I have to get through the day
this little French guy who's he was
great he's great director he still
directs yeah he's like in his 80s it's
great I think he's still going do you
remember
um the feeling you got when you got this
Larger than Life I mean this is at the
time a 35 million dollar movie the
budget I mean a lot of big people are in
this movie they have a clip because they
were filming when they told me that I
got the part I was at Pinewood Studios
there's a clip of you reacting there's a
documentary on the making of Supergirl
and you see me walking into the room
with the sulkins and Timothy Pearl and
the cameras on and they're like
you know thank you for coming and then
you got the part you know so your eyes
light up oh I start crying like I'm just
I you know my whole life changed your
whole life changed like massive
massively changed how many times did you
test for this
I went in Lynn stallmaster was casting I
don't know if it was once or twice and
then the screen test was the big thing
where they flew me to London and I don't
know who else or how many other people
that might be in the documentary but I
just haven't seen it in so many years
were you intimidated
um were you nervous around big stars
like Faye Dunaway or Peter O'Toole or my
my
singular memory of just the one I mean
so many years ago it's so it's 40 years
ago 41 years ago yeah
um they really did it very smartly if
I'm speaking correctly so Alf joined who
trained Chris Reeve trained me so when I
flew to London I was by myself I had no
chaperone or anything like that but I
trained for four months just gaining 15
20 pounds weight training trampolining
horseback riding fencing
every possible swimming three times a
week
I was in such a rigor running at the
back lot of Pinewood Studios and I met
one of my dear friends who was my stunt
double Tracy Eden Now Tracy Michaels so
my point is it really grew you know I
was in London in this cocoon so by the
time it came to meeting Peter O'Toole or
meeting Faye Dunaway or
I was in such a I felt like I was the
Moss that was attached to the whole
thing like it was intimidating and but
you were prepared so prepared like it
wasn't just coming like now you know
what it's like you get a part and you
have like three days or something and
you're just trying to get those six
pages of dialogue memories yeah it's so
not a way to work